[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
we gotta tell them about durham october
29th
durham performing arts center dorm is in
north carolina north carolina is in the
united states yes we will be there
co-headlining just like we did in
baltimore ask the people at the lyric
there how much they love that show we
co-headline we do some stand-up and then
we come in at the end we take some
questions from the crowd you gotta be
there during performing arts center
october 29th ladies leave your man at
home the club is full of ballers and
their pockets full grown and all you
fellas leave that girl with her friends
cause it's 11 a.m and the club is hey
hey babe hey babe what's up babe how you
doing bubbies i'm doing
you decent the eyes are over stimulated
today yeah i was telling you that i have
like i think like it's my ocd and when i
get over stimulated you have adhd i got
every i got everything you got i got add
adhd i got triple a
double amcl i got double yeah yeah yeah
i got that double find yourself singing
like jingles for commercials because
they did such a good job it gets in your
head like an earworm a hundred percent i
i you know like every i would say we may
have even said this on the podcast right
yeah where i said by men and when we
just say it all the time but i always
say you know what i find myself doing a
lot when i'm just walking around the
house liberty liberty liberty liberty
yeah i i
i do feel like the thing is i think with
the brain
of a comedian or like an artist
entertainer i think that and maybe it's
all even more than that but i feel like
our brains like
we kind of process the world like a
little differently like something that
somebody else might catch we catch but
then on the flip side you know a lot of
things that like you know
normal people catch we don't catch so i
think at the end of the day it's
balanced but my you're right we're keyed
in on certain things no one else is and
we're completely aloof on things that
most other people are right right so i
see that you're right so it's all it's
all it's all balancing but i i would
i'll tell you what's happening to me
yeah because you know i got there it is
yeah i got a case
the crazy overstimulus
this is crazy this is one of our
favorite characters this is nut bag sal
nut bag sal nbs
he pops up once every 50 apps and nut
bags he's a fun guy to have on hay bank
or sally nut bags
yeah um so you know i'm so exhausted
like like um
like a full i would say near mental
breakdown exhaustion you know which i
know you've gotten to be with all with
the workflow but mine is you know with
with with the kids the new house the the
the traveling so it's a near mental
exhaustion breakdown and my brain now
like my brain because i'm gonna be like
a therapy episode
buckle up betterhelp.com
10 off your first month 14 14 free meals
yes at
betterhelp.com.com
it helps you keep the better that you
yeah if you need a loan go to
keeps.com it's just like short
circuiting it's like do you want a
lasting erection yeah you better help i
i know i love that better help too it's
like 10 off the first month the second
month it's up to you so if you find
yourself swinging from the ceiling fan
that's a deal it's like you come to us
with a broken wing we give you time and
then we ask you to fly fly so but but
something's happened i don't know if if
maybe the listeners just happen to him
too maybe this is the thing because i've
heard on snl lauren michaels
will keep the writers locked i've heard
this i don't know if it's true we'll
keep the writers like locked in a room
till like four o'clock in the morning
especially in the beginning and make
their brains so tired and then that's
when they get the funniest sketches or
at least that's what they used to do
they get the funny sketch because their
brains are loopy so fried they're like
you know what how about this allegedly
like like cowbell all those yeah like
the they come out of like they came out
of 5 a.m allegedly but what's happened
to me in my brain and i don't know why
is
like yesterday
no not even it has nothing to do with
humor like yesterday it's almost like i
had a stroke and peop
you know you come back and you like have
like another brain i've been cooking
like i made a full
chicken parm with penny and vodka sauce
last night i don't know how to cook
i don't know how to cook i swear
i went i just i got chicken i said i
said to my family so i'm going to go to
the supermarket yeah and i went to this
chat and i guess we should probably cut
that part out that's too close to uh who
knows
so so by the way meghan trainor looks
like me if i was a woman
shout out twelve items or less express
line they bumped it up from ten items or
less do they really i don't think so i
said twelve and i see ten listen if
that's one go if that's one good thing
that pandemic gave us then god bless you
you ever on a line and someone's got
more than 10 and you're like
or you ever that guy that's got more
than 10 you try to sneak it in well see
here's what i think because when they
say items like for example if i got a
six pack of dan and yogurt shadow tenant
that's one item yeah shout out live and
active cultures but what shout out live
in our culture what if i have six
individual
yogurts i said you snapped them off the
six-pack no no i'm saying i got let's
say i got six in the six-pack yeah but
then i got six i got you you got six
yes individual yeah is that are those
six items oh yeah hey pot at gmail.com
to find out yeah um you listen we're not
we're not only doing polls on taste buds
here now we're doing falls on hey tweet
it out
um um but i just went to the store like
almost like my brain like i wasn't even
in my body like i was having almost like
a it's almost like i was on dmt were you
were you were you tasked with
covering dinner zero so you did it she
would have gladly cooked we had the food
in the fridge zero and we were out of
hello fresh that is a true thing um so
but don't you don't find you don't let
yourself be out of hello fresh um
did you get what kind of cutlass did you
get did you have to cut them and get all
the trimming no i'm not splatting them
and stuff i got i got i got skinless
chicken breasts okay you know just ready
to go ready ready to go ready to go
skinless chicken breasts i went we
didn't have any when i got home we found
out that i had we did have a lot of
stuff i got skinless chicken breasts i
got fresh mutts i got uh canned tomato
sauce i understand that's a horrible
thing to do but i i you know but can so
you made sauce then or you bought jar
jar tomatoes that's what i meant to say
right which one um uh pregnant
whoa
i i really want dartbag wow yeah yeah
you you went prego prego but that's even
that's not even ragu but you ready what
i did is that it's in there prego
but
the vodka sauce i got was bertolli
so i had two sauces i mixed well i told
you i made penny vodka and chicken parm
oh my god yes you made two separate
dishes you heated up the sauce out of
the juice yeah i mean it's all i ever do
i mean it's it's you know hideous like i
literally why did you reach for you were
at the market they have other brands
look there's probably a lot of nice
people at prego it's been around a long
time yeah probably feeds a lot of people
yeah people send their child through to
their school on that they have mortgages
they pay
so lovely people over at prego lovely
people over listen maybe for me
not not feel prego for us for for the
italians especially over here on the
northeast uh yeah that could be
sometimes thought of as as a like yeah
you don't want to go prego but then
again now that's all out the window
because people are picking up stuff like
the the more like the rails and [ __ ]
like that yeah yeah unless you i'm like
listen but there was other options you
reached for the pregame i got bertolli
vodka sauce and i got prego and you
might be you might be sitting at home
prego eating prego right now right good
for you your child might have diabetes
what can you do but i i got probably
fine
most i mean listen i mean i just you
know what i haven't even had it who am i
to cast stones if i made a sauce i'm
sure prego would kill my sauce listen
prego
prego is fda approved fauci said it was
so it's fda approved it's fine but
i got the prego tomato sauce which was
dumb and then i got the bertoli
alfredo sauce uh the holy vodka sauce
which i i didn't even think twice about
it i was just in the mood then i got the
chicken cuts i got penne i got penne
then i got an entenmann's crumb cake
which you know i love it ultimate
uh ultimate or regular no cinnamon
cinnamon crumb cake oh okay but was it
was it like the regular is the thin
layer of the crumb and the ultimate is
like mostly crumb and like twenty
percent layer then yeah okay see yeah
it's not as delicious but it is not also
not as healthy question i got halo top
ice cream to go with it too you did oh
so you went healthy
did you dip did you break eggs and and
do the bread crumbs and all that stuff
absolutely i did and how did you do the
breadcrumbs four seasons breakfast
bread comes shout out forces breadcrumbs
shout out four seasons iced tea i like
4c you like 4c is it for cf4 seasons i
say four seasons or maybe maybe there's
four seasons it's been a while it's been
a while once the breadcrumb wins the
hotel i can never tell you right so
so i
i take them all that i took a bowl was
vinnie like uh what are you doing what
did you hit your head no yes she was
like are you just gonna really make
dinner right now and i was like yeah go
ahead i was like take care of the kids
do whatever you want you're like i can
cook it i said no no go ahead have fun
with the kids so i but literally i was
doing it and oil in the pan yeah and you
know what i also have been doing too on
loop for no reason i think because me
and pimp you know when we came back from
baltimore and then i did a show in
pittsburgh shout out jurgles that was
that was a venue i did after baltimore
with with south the lyric theater but we
were listening to kanye west's old album
for some reason on a loop like my brain
just goes into like this setting on a
loop i've been listening to the song
through the wire so i would
you know right down to the y that
kanye's one of like his breakthrough
songs where he's
singing with his jaw why aren't you yeah
i've been listening to that song i mean
i'm not lying about 50 times in a row
yeah while i'm making the food and i
don't know what i'm like it's like it's
like my brain's not in my body yeah so i
crack the eggs i crack three to four
eggs
put the breadcrumb in mix it all around
and then i start laying last time you
did this was never
you made your first chicken cutlet ever
first you can call it ever oh my god
chicken cutlet
was it fun
it actually wasn't bad i kind of were
you like enjoying doing it it you know
clean up sucks the cleanup the cleanup
well to be tbh the dishes are still in
the sink yeah so we didn't clean up it
because as i said i'm exhausted right so
i did do it um and the dishwasher is
broken in the brand new house that i
bought so there's a lot of things the
previous owners didn't disclose but what
can you do that's the way the cookie
crumbles shut out staten island right so
so so i i i i put i put
i
pounded the chicken which i just i
didn't know what that meant but i i
heard that you have to pound the chicken
i swear to god i
did like that because i thought you had
to fly now normally you have that like
freaking mallet or whatever no so i just
went like that right um
so i put five or six cutlets in put them
in you understand oil and oil
temperatures i don't so that's the other
thing i put in olive oil i put olive oil
i put olive oil bertoli olive oil it's
got to be um oh extra virgin olive oil
is what i use is it extra virgin it's
got to be so it doesn't burn
or is the extra virgin not the one you
cook with no you probably cook so i'll
tell you what i did i i put the i put
xvo
no relation in drake so i put evo then i
put i put the bread crumbs the eggs i
put it all in and then you know what i
did on the side again out of my mind i
don't know what i'm doing i took honey
hunt like actual bees honey and french's
mustard and a little salt and pepper and
i made like a honey mustard like dijon
dipping sauce before i had the idea to
make the chicken parm so i had a honey
dijon this is a thousand percent drill
you can confirm this with vinnie i had a
honey dijon mustard dipping sauce but
this just came off the top of your head
it was i'm telling you did you ever make
a
from scratch honey dijon sauce zero what
was going on
i did it it's almost like you you you
hit your head and you were a different
person so i'm saying like you see those
videos where like somebody has a stroke
or gets struck by lightning and they
just wake up when they're speaking in
another language yes that's what
happened it was like something unlocked
in my brain wow where i was like so some
people that happen to when they paint
picasso some people happen to when they
can speak french for you you make a
honey mustard do you make a mean honey
still yeah i i i'll pound chicken
cutlets like on mike tyson
who is this guy all of a sudden he
became a honey mustard artisan yeah yeah
a brick a brick fell over construction
site hit him in the head you know he has
his own line of honey mustard in stores
i'm chrissy cutlets so
so so um um so i make the cutlets i say
you know what i don't i don't know if
this is right for the honey mustard
let's save that anymore so i have the
honey mustard with aluminum foil in the
fridge right now um um
i i said you know what let's let's make
a chicken parm so that it's there it's
all um though all the the all the
chicken is is in the pan i put aluminum
foil in a pan shallow rental trap i put
aluminum foil right it was really for me
reynolds is is the go-to wrap yeah i i
know there's other aluminum foil brands
which is fine but reynolds wrap is what
i feel secure with it is it's what i
grew up with and i like the heavy duty
really feels i'm getting the most lock
when i like that when i'm performing
when i'm putting it around a a
a dish that's what i like i like i'm a
rental trap guy so
so i put it in the pan did you say tin
foil still or no i say tin foil i get
mock roundly when i say tin foil tin
foil like what my mom they grew up
saying did did it at one point switch
from din to aluminum or or people just
always calling it tin by accident i
think people
tin foil might be a regional thing you
think tinfoil
you know like if we go to iowa tomorrow
and we say if we say tin foil they say
are you some kind of conspiracy nut
because now that's the ten hats yeah
what is aluminum foil or tin foil oh i
guess it's the same thing i but i tell
you people mock me when i say tin foil i
mean i'm getting to the point faster
aluminum is a long word
and by the way i understand i've and i i
understand the british language the
english language and how beautiful it is
and how we say a lot of dumb words
aluminium
is what they say and i just wanted i
want to get that out yeah i know that
you're more proper and better but i want
to get aluminium aluminum um i want that
out it's a little true a lot of things
they say i'd say nine out of ten things
they they i like it better with the way
they say it
you know except do you like vitamins i
don't like vitamins i like vitamins and
i like aluminum yeah so i'd like to get
rid of vitamins
uh
um i'd like to i'd like to go out yeah
get that out all right so
i put
and again just no youtube no asking my
family for help nothing i said you go in
the other room you go in the other room
and i know it's been sleeping over my
house every day you missed the one day
when i could
so but i'm gonna do it again because let
me tell you what happened so you're like
i didn't use youtube like how to make
penne yeah they're like one open bertoli
pour in
um
so so so yeah the penne you know i was
boiling the water i had ever thrown that
in i knew what to do with that i put it
in for 12 minutes i'll dent which is out
then what is out there a little bit a
little bit with a snap a little bit hard
still not mush 12 minutes i put it in i
have no clue no clue no so then i put
that pasta in a strainer let it strained
out let it sit there in the sink while i
got the cutlets fr uh a baked in the
oven i put it in the oven you did baked
cutlets i set it up to foam i thought
you did the oil but i set it up to 425
degrees i put all that on the pan i put
all that in no oh you coated the pan
with oil you didn't fry the cutlets no
the bowl i i had like a big bowl which i
thought was a ball used for kitchen and
then jasmine told me it was a bowl used
for plants but it's fine
she told me it was clean so she's like
chris why are you frying cutlets in the
planter yeah yeah so but it was a clean
bubble but it was up where the bowls are
but she's like that's one that i used to
plant
you never in the kitchen where's the
food you're like it's in the vault yeah
yeah
so so
so i put what i took that you know glass
bowl and i put extra virgin olive oil um
um extra virgin olive oil uh
bread crumbs salt pepper and something
else to make the thing to coat the
cutlets
oh but doesn't the oil in effect
ruin the bread crumb the way i always
did it was you dumped the cutlet in egg
okay
and then you put it in like flour or the
um the bread crumb and you and and the
stickiness from the egg is what coats
the mine's stuck but when you put oil in
the breadcrumb ahead of time didn't it
coax like clump it up no it still i mean
it looks like a cutlet to me okay great
somewhat of a maybe i'm maybe okay so
maybe i'm learning something so i put i
put the the stove on 450 degrees
fahrenheit
so
i don't know that was so funny
i love it let's let's let's make a
package just get rid of in height and
height yeah oh fat height let's get rid
of height no 450 450 pounds
450 fahren so
so 450 million fahren so
so i put so i put that on i wait i
waited till it beeped because i
preheated the oven then when it beeped i
had my cutlets an extra virgin olive oil
bread crumb eggs with honey mustard
sauce on the side in a bowl separate i
put that in and then i realized oh i but
there's no parmesan so then i took wild
it was i literally i had my mitts on
already to put it in the oven but i had
the tray out
of the ketchup
yeah no i actually have like the you
know like the real good oven mitts so so
i put the other real good ones yeah so i
opened up with the mitts on my hand
opened up the bertolli's uh the prego
tomato sauce and poured it all over each
cutlet i used a whole can of it which
that's the only thing my family's like
this is you wait too much sauce put the
whole can over that and then i sprinkle
fresh mozzarella cheese on all of it and
then for no reason at all but my family
said they actually taste good i put red
hot chili pepper flakes all over those
are good but you gotta use them in
moderation so i just did a quick
sprinkle yeah and then i put that in and
i baked those for about 15 minutes so
you bake the cutlets with the sauce on
them yes which i was which which you
know is something different now
which you know
is something different but is that a
thing is that a technique
again i have in my head the cutlets
would come out baked and the sauce would
be made and then when you serve it you
put the color on then you drop the sauce
on it at that point but again
lips i have no clue if you know i don't
cook either so maybe that's just another
technique or another way it came out
phenomenal phenom i i mean
well
my family said it was my family said
bottom line is it's not like i mean it's
still gonna food is food it's not like
it's yeah you're still baking a fresh
chicken cutlet and putting sauce on it
with vodka sauce i did what you said is
i i had the vodka sauce and then i
poured it on the penne as it was coming
out so we had penny vodka sauce but at
one time the only thing you know she was
like i would have done this differently
at one time i served the penny vodka
sauce the chicken parm and the entmans
with the halo top so i i did it all like
one you got and you and of course that
made my six-year-old an eleven-year-old
be like i'm only gonna eat the ice cream
cake right so she was like next time you
try to cook i really appreciate this
yeah but don't don't let them see the
cake in the ice cream they have to eat
their food first
but listen i didn't make me want to cook
tonight well i did it because i was
exhausted i was genuinely like and it's
weird because i was like my brain went
into this overdrive where i did it i
never wear flannels once you ever see me
walking today and i noted that in my own
head i said well that's a whole new look
for you look at me i'm wearing it's
cause i'm exhausted i said i wanna look
great actually wait a minute something's
going on i think you're possessed i
think something happened in jurgles and
there's a country star inside here
yes there's a lesbian that's gotten
inside them
i mean so you could i mean no you've
cooked from hello
i cooked hello fresh yeah but not
pre-packaged not scratch so maybe hello
hello fresh gave me the confidence to
just come out here wow
wow yeah and then and then and then this
morning this morning i woke up and you
know my family was like oh you know i'm
gonna make breakfast and
i i kind of was a i was thinking like
hey maybe i could who wants prego and
eggs prego and eggs but we couldn't do
it we couldn't do eggs so instead of
course i went with magic spoon have you
cooked eggs before cook the eggs i have
actually eggs because and eggs eggs what
i do there is they crack them you beat
them you beat them in the thing with a
fork you beat them with a fork a little
bit i put salt pep
and then um i put a little bit of milk
wow almond
no
cows
yeah
well i don't i haven't eaten cow's milk
eating cow's milk and forever but yeah i
used to do it once have you drink cow's
milk uh it's got to be a while so you go
on incidentally i'll drink it like if
i'm getting a coffee and they only have
regular milk i have it but i haven't
purchased it or used it in my cereal or
to dunk my cookies in in in ages only
almond do you go oh um i'd do an oat
almond thing yeah i got oat nam and
downstairs on the mood you know what i
have you know what i have in the fridge
right now
uh from um uh i think it's called almond
barista it's almond pumpkin flavored
almond milk creamer phenomenal i put
that in my cereal did i put cream oh i
did it that's not good that loads up the
couch that's right man i think creamer
is very bad right like you know you know
when they give you those little little
shot glasses creamer yeah i think one of
those is like a lot of saturation almost
pimp has lost a thousand pounds every
all right cutting out creams no no cut
out creams that's all he does is drink
coffee all he does is drink coffee or
cream drink beers and eat a salad a day
he's lost like 50 pounds he drinks
coffee with creamer all day i think of
your cream is keto and i'm not joking
but i think you said it's bad for you
well if you only drink if you're only
doing straquito i think it definitely
has oh no because it might have sugar
too no maybe it doesn't the pumpkin
spice coffee cream from i believe it's
called almond barista the company it's
so good it was good you had it yeah you
got it at the house trans fat on how
sometimes i'll come downstairs i don't
even know pimp slept over i'm just in my
house yeah he's just sitting he's
sitting i know we made it in our little
guest room for you we made a little uh
uh jasmine made a little corner for you
so you can do your work in the room yeah
i've been editing like in the middle
what's uh that movie half baked who's on
the couch the whole time was it uh
brewer it's brew right yeah yeah
um so yeah so that's so i've been so
exhausted my brain's been short
circuiting that now i'm picking up this
new habit and and oh and another thing
we had to put um
floor in our garage we wanted to turn
into like a gym space so we put down gym
flooring i put down with me and another
guy i put down the flooring in my own
gym yesterday morning wow because i was
a dead exhausted
i'm sorry you you were exhausted so you
did hard manual labor yeah
you were exhausted so you lay the floor
i lay the floor i don't know if it's
because i'm exhausted i've also been
pumped up on terraflow it could be the
theraflu or the exhaustion but one of
them is making me cook and lay down
flooring wow yeah you're becoming
domesticated i'm domesticated guy i
think it's you have you had a second
baby you got a house now you're cooking
and laying down florida i'm cooking the
laying down flooring because you know
what it is you know what it is i think
once you have a house you're wearing
flannels i'm wearing dude i'm a
carpenter maybe i'm am i jesus is this
your mid-life crisis i think i'm having
a mid-life christmas oh i'm having a big
time midnight big time i'm having a big
time in life yeah well you haven't
gotten a haircut in two years i know
look at me
i love it though we get ready and i
can't like do my hair the way i normally
wear it and so this is a cheat where i
got to slick it back but then i look
like
patrick bateman from from
from uh american psychology
i like but you know what i think that's
one of his best movies i know but i'm
not this guy
i look like
between a biker and someone that does
like taekwondo i look like steven seagal
this is not me no i this is
this is directly from covered quarantine
my hair got this long and then when i
when i don't because my hair is it just
looks like super like wavy like right so
if i don't do it the right way
it can't i can't show my face so this is
just a real quick cheat i throw some
water in it and i slick it back so i can
come up here and do and and have a good
time with you but i like but for me i i
say it almost every episode it works i
hate it for you it works i hate it so
why don't you shave the head
on the patreon
why did you do your eyebrows because i
kind of just went nuts i was 17 years
old i i told the story right already
pimp i think when i shaved it and it was
so white because i picked it and i got a
sunburn on the top of my head oh no i
didn't think i noticed that but why did
you why would you shave your eyebrows i
was 17 and i just i still don't
understand
like i don't why would a 17 year old
shave their eyebrows i kind of don't i
i don't know maybe i was like you maybe
i was exhausted you took them off yeah
fully off i never forget my dad was you
know my parents are divorced my dad was
at the house like he was watching me or
whatever hanging out at my house and i
came out and he was and he's looking at
me
and because i might have had the head
shaved and he's like what are you doing
and i was like what are you talking
about he goes did you shave your
eyebrows like he noticed immediately you
when you remove your eyebrows it's an
immediate i know we took off murray's on
the show and then made him get a new
driver's license yeah no but as soon as
they took him off he looks like a
different person yeah you look like
you're just a flesh thumb yeah that's
what i look like i look like a worm yeah
yeah so so and i remember that it looks
like a testicle a testicle yeah about
what but was it a goof did you or did
you try to put like a
like like a vanilla ice track in there
and then you just went too far like what
what why did you put the razor to your
eye
to be honest with you i don't recall in
that moment it was 20 years ago why i
did it but i do remember
doing it and then second back like this
looks pretty good and then
and then my father immediately be like
what'd you do my girlfriend at a time be
like what'd you do my mother's screaming
they take so long to come back
they don't grow at the rate of regular
hair yeah there's things that i
there's things that i did there's things
that i did
that
there's things that i did that i think i
just blocked out because like when i
even when i shaved and bicked my head
like you have to understand like when i
bicked my head
given at least two to three months to
see here grow
it must have taken that long but i just
blow it out look the hair growth cycle
for eyebrows is between three and four
months it must have taken that long wow
yeah it was bad it was bad because i had
a fully bicked like my my face was tan
and the top of my head was milky son had
never hit it now like did you go through
a tough phase because you sound like a
young gang member yeah when i was 7 16
17 well i told you i had my hair braided
i thought it was like i thought i played
that thing or i was like i'm the tough
guy you need we need did you ever show
us braden and i've been
trying to take home footage of tough guy
chris you need to well i mean the
picture that of me wearing the dallas
couch like vhs tape i want to hear how
you talk
hell yeah we got i i need to see you and
that's one thing i regret that i'm that
i'm happy that we have now and that my
kids will have is i don't have i have
almost zero home video footage of me i
don't think i don't think i have any
like zero not from when i'm a kid not
from when i'm a kid oh my god of course
i was i'm from 92. so i definitely do
but i mean i want to talk to your mom my
mom might have my father when i was
young they rocked those like holding on
your shoulder cam yeah and and not
everyone had that like no that was no
one had that so i i think i i have like
and then and then it was on vhs
it's a full vhs and then i don't think
anyone transferred those digital vhs
i've done it for chad okay i'm going to
find this
yeah let's see if i got any young ones
but yeah i i i just clipped that let's
see if i got any my dad
my dad has like six photos of himself as
a kid
you know what i mean like we don't have
videos they don't have photos yeah my
phone i only have a couple of hundred
photos of me as a kid my friend yeah how
much more can you have dude my fault
my father
it's like one of those stories where
you're like that can't be true but it is
my father is one of five
in a one-bedroom apartment in the bronx
five siblings two parents and both his
grandparents lived in the same apartment
whoa so that's in five s nine people
lived in one apartment in the bronx
that's wild that's like i used to be and
i saw a picture once again with
everybody in the in the living rooms
like that's everybody we had one toilet
and one bath one bedroom i was like but
how did it physically work he said my
grandparents slept in the room my mother
and father slept on a pullout couch he
said and then we had uh
like bunk bed they had one bunk bed like
in like a like a little like hallway
space and then they just had mattresses
but he said you know it was two to a bed
yeah you make do yeah i was like that's
crazy i i mean i've heard like my my
family has done that i have like spanish
family that had a lot of people living
in
i got no wrapper on is that okay yeah i
went raw dog
oh you find me going wrong with this
yeah you're going to you're comfortable
yeah i'm not i've just been tested no my
only only thing is the thing so your
your thing is if you're going to put it
on then put it on all the way yes
because if it's even a little off then
we can't do it but if we're going to go
off then we're going all the way off the
rail it's off i'm a lunatic yeah the ocd
is too much dude nut bags out number
exiles are great when nutbag sal shows
up it's a fun app oh my god when i when
i talk when i went for my first ever job
interview
it was in
1999 and i and i went to prudential and
did you party like it was or maybe we
just party like it was okay yeah yeah
yeah just making sure i i went in and
the guy i have a thing i told you about
my ocd with points you know you know
this yeah of course yeah so and i think
i might maybe if it stopped me if you
heard it uh i sat down the guy had uh on
his desk i was doing an interview with
he had stacks of papers and i'm sitting
in front of it and all the papers are
like caddy corner like they're pointing
and then he had uh this thing with two
fountain pens in it and the pens were
facing toward me right and so i sat down
i was already i could even see the pain
in you just telling the story i was
already over stimulated and then the the
interview was like 40 minutes
and we like hit it off but i was sitting
there and i was doing this thing where i
was like crunching my toes because i
must have looked like this while i was
talking to him because that's what you
look like this whole pocket i know i
know i know and i can't zoom in on his
face the whole time
i couldn't i couldn't um
you know touch his pen and turn it the
other way yeah so he was like asking me
questions like and i was like oh you
can't do it yeah something happens and i
get real like tense and i start like
squirming it's a real mental piece of
[ __ ] of course you know like
i want to know like at what age did you
first realize i hate corners like when
did it hit you oh my god i don't i truly
don't know but it's been happening for
as long as i can remember like six seven
well i told you my sister jacked my eye
up and i i i i think it's from that she
hit me in the face you know with that
malibu kendall
and uh i i trace it back to this
the injury to the eye but i truly don't
know i think it's really just has to do
with ocd but i feel like you feel i feel
like when i'm over stimulated i don't
feel like myself yeah i feel like a
complete lunatic yeah do you everything
gets so over stimulated like this
happens to me sometimes well like i'll
need to know
something that's like six months away
but i'll need to know like what the plan
is for that day today like right now
yeah and but it does like i'll need to
know like it's whatever october and i'll
be like where are we going for christmas
what time do you need to be at christmas
what time should i be there and it's
like what does it matter it's two and a
half months away oh the exact opposite
did you ever get to a point where you
you literally
cannot process a single piece of
information like you go on complete you
go complete over you go overheat right
and and you don't even know how to i've
been there and i've been there recently
you don't even know how to
speak to someone like i i got like it's
almost like a breakdown and you're just
like i i i people could ask you like the
simplest question yeah just like oh do
you know if you'll be back in time or do
you want to eat something and i'm just
like
i i'm sorry i can't i can't answer you
right now
that's bad mental health is this is bad
it's bad yeah that's why they say
meditation really helps if you can
meditate because then you can just slow
your you want to do like a quick
meditation you want to meditate for the
last few minutes of the pod yeah i mean
we could why don't we do it we could do
a guided you want to guide it you want
to ask our listeners to just relax and
close their eyes why don't you guys
relax and close your eyes let's see if
we can i mean is this the last few
minutes of the pod now
well since we have some time i might as
well shout out tom brady for him winning
the super bowl oh my god and the new and
then not even the new england patriots
tampa bay buccaneers yeah he must
meditate yeah you don't win
championships as the oldest person in
the nfl without meditating no dude and
he also never ate a strawberry in his
life
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
patrick mahomes
also being the runner-up yeah young hot
quarterback you think pat patty patty
mahomes uh you think he's
he meditates or do you think he's a
young hot shot and he doesn't need to do
it i think he's probably a young hottie
so he doesn't meditate right now but i
mean tb definitely meditates tv has to
meditate yeah tuberculosis yeah yeah
yeah um um yeah i i think
hysterically we just meditate in silence
for the rest of the part for i mean
literally just every second guys are
your credit cards bills keeping you up
at night interest rates in double digits
i'm up at night too a lot of it though
i'm peeing a lot more in the middle of
the night now i'm gonna google it but
let's get back to live stream please uh
be smart and pay off your credit card
balances with a credit card
consolidation loan form from live stream
rates start at just 4.98
with auto pay and excellent credit plus
the rate's fixed it'll never go up over
the life of the loan five thousand to a
hundred thousand dollars there's
absolutely no fees you get your money as
soon as the day you apply it it's
possible to do livestream believes that
people with good credit deserve a better
loan experience and that's why they
deliver okay so just for our listeners
apply now to get a special interest rate
discount and save even more the only way
to get this discount is to go to
lightstream.com
hey babe
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
hey babe i gotta read this disclaimer
for you it's subject to credit approval
rates range from 4.9 percent apr to
19.99
apr and include a 0.50
auto pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice visit
livestream.com for more information guys
i want to talk to you about crowd health
because i think a lot of us realize that
we have a broken health insurance system
we go back and forth trying to fix it
and argue about what's best and this is
something that's new and exciting
because let's face it half of americans
are playing paying crazy high
deductibles uh they're on hook for
thousands of bucks and stuff and it's
like being
being just stuck it's like being stuck
with an outdated
cable tv plan and you didn't know there
was a streaming service there's just a
better way to do it now it isn't health
insurance it's a better way to pay
medical expenses it's called crowdhealth
and it's a community of people who are
tired of paying for the broken system a
place where you can get simple flexible
affordable way to pay your health care
uh being in the community the crown
health community can save hundreds of
dollars monthly and put thousands back
in your pocket so here's the deal it's
flexible membership is a monthly
subscription you can start or stop
whenever it's convenient for you that's
huge that there's no commitment i don't
know anything else like that it's simple
and transparent pricing customized to
fit your needs you could use the app and
you could find a doctor in in in any
country almost any country and they rank
them from one to five stars you scan
your bills you throw them away crowd
health takes it from there you upload
your bills to the app and they work on
it for you press a button to receive
virtual care anytime it's like having a
doctor in your pocket a community of
health conscious members who want to get
and stay healthy in return for low
prices that's who joins us
they get rid of the insurance middleman
and you get those savings 100
of the membership fees pay for the
actual health care which helps the whole
crowd health community stay healthy
while putting more money in your pocket
it's kind of crowd funding health care
um crown health is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community and
health conscious members
so for a limited time our listeners get
their first month free so that's
healthcare for free
and after you've been a member
crowdhealth will include a fitness
wearable that's 30 days to try risk-free
plus a fitness wearable which i'm
assuming is a fun little
fitness gadget uh just go to
joincrowdhealth.com
fit and enter our code hey babe at sign
up that's join crowdhealth.com
fit fit and the promo code is hey babe
of course crowdhealth is not health
insurance it's community-powered
alternative terms and conditions may
apply
dude did you see this hundreds of
speaking of eye stuff
hundreds of weird three-eyed dinosaur
shrimp have emerged after heavy rain so
now there's these three-eyed shrimp
that came out ew of nowhere
of nowhere they've come out and not like
scientists don't know what the hell to
do i i haven't i've never even seen a
two-white or a one on a shrimp i don't
think i've ever seen a shrimp's face
yeah
yeah when we look at shrimp that we eat
that's not what yeah oh no yeah shrimp
it looks like a little mini lobster
right like a prawn yeah what is it if
you would have told me right now shrimps
have three eyes i'd say yeah okay don't
know i don't know who's looking at
shrimp's faces i eat their bodies why
are they dying tracks yeah oh that's
what they say is that is that true
though i heard it's true
is that if you don't clean the shrimp
and is that is that true that that's a
digestive tract it is true i believe it
is true i remember the the first time i
heard that because it stuck with me ever
again and like i will not eat a shrimp
that is not there it is right that's
their like oh yeah that's true it's
totally in calamari they say if you go
to a a bad place calamari is imitation
calamari it's actually pig anus that's
what they say that's how they get around
calamaris big anus and grated cheese is
loaded up with plastic it's not all
grated cheese it's it's plastic bits
it's really the grated cheese is about
half of the container and they fill the
rest of it up with plastic and babe you
ready for this so much plastic in the
world pimp get hold it buckle up balls
are about to be blown off all right you
thought they sparkled in yeah they're
balls and everyone got their balls
okay
so
babies now being born 21 are being born
with plastic in their blood to so much
to the point in the next thousand years
keeps going plastic will be
a thing essential for humans to survive
it'll be part of our dna that's how much
covered in plastic we are babies right
now have plastic in their blood
you heard that
oh my god babies have 15 times more
microplastic in their bodies than adults
look at that so we all have micro yeah
because it's you know it's in the sea
and then
the animals eat the plastic goes in them
we eat the animal that's all that's all
it is
the son the son not your son yeah don't
let your son go down on me it's not the
words you know what i used to think
because do you know what i used to think
was so weird
[Music]
maybe it was the original words you
never know i used to think can you
change it to the when princess diana
died elton john wrote the song candle in
the light
yeah
for princess diana but i thought that
this is how like a little kid's brain
works i thought that he wrote the song
circle of life and made the movie lion
king for princess diana no i did not
i always remember being a kid
i know he had nothing to do with that
but in my head i thought if you talk to
this eight-year-old me i say l i would
tell my mom i would say to you if you
said what's the lion king about it well
it's a movie about the african jungle
where you know a lion a story about
lions and hyenas and and just uh you
know cool story with jonathan taylor
thomas from home improvement uh shout
out jonathan jtt but i would say but it
was made because el princess diana died
sadly and suddenly elton john made this
movie to commemorate her life a movie
about african lions
because the british princess died was it
candle in the wind about um
uh marilyn monroe but didn't he sing it
for at princess diana's funeral oh
probably that would be oh
because he's goodbye no magine norma
genius maryland i think he even says
marilyn monroe but i thought it was all
just singing it for princess i thought
she was a marilyn monroe fan no i think
that he wrote that as an ode to marilyn
but then it was fitting
for princess dog yeah that's correct
cantaloupe is a
what is that word
written in 1970 what's green what does
that word say a serenity you know where
candle in the wind is a
threnody
what the
trinity is a wailing ode song hymn or
poem of mourning composed or performed
as a memorial to a dead person the term
originates from the greek word
spanikopita
from john stamos the latter ultimately
from the photo into the urine rope hvad
yeah
yeah all right so we just learned
something a serenity is a wailing ode to
a to a past present
word of the day that's right trinity was
elasticity last issue now
now it's threatening by the way shout
out to the people who brought us
elasticity shirt they gave us a shirt in
uh baltimore thank you for the
elasticity merch we love you we love you
and just to go back to the dinosaur
shrimp that are coming out because
everything's melting and getting so thin
there's now a woolly mammoth tusk boom
in russia where they're making millions
of dollars selling like woolly mammoths
to have thought out from everything's
thawing out old diseases old creatures
oh
so cold nights so what we're going
through now could be an old one i've
been seeing woolly mammoths in the in
the news this week well because we have
they have they've dna preserved and they
can make they want to bring them back
they want to bring woolly mammoths back
which i think is a fun looking elephant
they have fun hair they're the only
outfits that have haircuts yeah they are
going to be the funnest elephant at that
gathering 100
yeah i like the african elephant i
really do but a woolly mammoth woolly
mammoth yeah what i mean it's full of
wool it's wool yeah but what do we do
we'll bring them back and then do we'll
do what with them we just let him go
pimp had a great idea thank you so much
we talked about this on last week's
episode it's a woolly mammoth did we
talk about that on chrissy chaos no no
we talked about it about how you think
it's going to be rich persons extinct
zoos
and like oh right
chris said they're going to start
cloning um like george washington and
lock him in an exhibit
possible
oh right because we talked about ted
williams and stuff right yeah well how
big is a woolly mammoth is it like is it
as big as an elephant or is it gonna be
bigger than shaq
yeah
it's got to be bigger than shaquille
o'neal yeah
yeah really
male woolly mammoths were thought to
reach shoulder heights of up to 3.5
meters which again i know that and i'm
so thankful for listeners all over the
world i really appreciate the people
from the uk and australia and all the
other nations who listen to this podcast
but you got to stop with meters okay
yeah you got to give me feeder inches
because i can't convert meters
to inches i just did a kilometer to mile
uh how i went on google and i had to do
it there's a formula sorry it's it is it
is very um
it is inconvenient for us everybody over
there well here look so if you could
just adjust your metric system and
there's a formula that i wrote down i
don't know why like this this stuck with
me this spoke to me but i have now
there's a formula now where i know how
to convert
fahrenheit to celsius and celsius back
to fahrenheit so i always get confused
with that because it doesn't track it's
not apples to apples so if so i think
that like zero degrees celsius is 32
fahren i think no you ready so to
convert fahren to celsius you multiply
by two and add 30. so if it's if it's 60
degrees
if it's if it's celsius wait
fahrenheit to celsius is multiplied by
two
and add 30. no that's just
celsius to fahrenheit so if it's two
degrees celsius two degrees it's two
degrees celsius right now what you do is
you multiply that by two so you say four
and then you add thirty so it's 34
degrees does it check out fahrenheit
no i just wrote down the equation no but
i'm saying see if that
that does that check out like can you
put in what is put in what is put okay
before you do it before we do it i'm
saying that two degree let's do five
okay it's five degrees celsius so i'm
gonna say five degrees celsius is forty
found it's 40 fahrenheit let's see what
what is five degrees celsius in
fahrenheit 41.
see it's not exact but i'm close yeah
you're close but will that work with
everything put 25 degrees fahrenheit
wholesale celsius hold on
let me just go right in the box no i
know but i want to see if i get this
right 25 degrees celsius so 80 degrees
fahrenheit let's see if it's 80 degrees
fahrenheit
77. i mean what it though
don't bleep that out
it's it's it's it's it's it's close and
then if you reverse if you want to go
fahrenheit to celsius subtract 30 divide
by two so let's say it's 50 degrees
celsius you go 20 divided by 2 that
would be 10 degrees fahrenheit
let's see
you know 50 fahren
50 fahrenheit right it's going to be 10.
yeah yeah
wow
okay celsius they're using it over there
too they use it over there who uses
kelvin
i don't even know who you must be the
taliban must be the only ones who use
kelvin does the taliban use calvin email
the podcast
um
i don't know there's too many scales you
know there's just too many scales
um i i kind of feel like there should be
one
i kind of think we're at the point
because we are so connected
we're so connected and i'm not saying it
has to be the american way but we should
have a big conference get all the
leaders and everybody and just have a
vote yeah and let's just pick one let's
pick one group measurement one religion
i agree one speaking too many scales
[Music]
too many scales
what's up with the hotel scale
i don't need why are they giving the
scales in the hotel because i want to
get fat and dirty in a hotel i'm i'm on
vacation or i'm i'm i'm out i'm
somewhere for work that's where i am i'm
bleeding i want to know my weight i
don't want to know it you think i want
to step on that scale before i go down
to the hotel pool i don't i don't i
don't want to know anything about the
hotel you smelly
it's almost like the freaking hotel
scales like uh before you go you want to
make sure you don't have to wear a
t-shirt
hello fresh is my favorite meal kit and
it's america's number one meal kit as
well
we talk about hello fresh all the time i
can talk about it without reading the
copy because i love it so much uh they
send delicious food right to my door i
choose what i want look
fall can be hectic that's coming up you
got kids going back to school you got
the holidays make it easier views people
with families single people people on
dates that's a fun date night that you
can do hello fresh office 50 menu and
market items the ingredients travel from
farm to your door uh there's recipes
they're fun like they're family recipes
like meatloaf a la mom or one pot
broccoli mac and cheese they make it
easy
it's not just for meals the marketplace
features a variety of snacks like this
this falls pumpkin cinnamon rolls that's
a lot of fun um yeah so i i use it i
love it it it it encourages me to cook
and it makes it fun pip could you just
scroll down a little bit right there um
go to hellofresh.com hey babe 14 which
is the thing i love a lot too because
you use hey babe the code hey babe 14
for up to 14 free meals including free
shipping so you got to go to
hellofresh.com
hey babe 14 and put in our code hey babe
14 for up to 14 males including shipping
america's number one meal kit we love
them hello fresh
i take my ritual vitamins every single
day
uh and i do not miss and i feel better
for it so let's talk about ritual we
deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and when it comes to
something we take every day we should
know that's why rituals clean
vegan friendly multivitamin are uh
they're formulated with high quality
nutrients in a bioavailable form your
body can actually use you won't find
sugars gmos major allergens synthetic
fillers artificial colorants all the bad
stuff is not in it okay plus they taste
fresh and they have delayed
release capsules uh making taking your
vitamins easy uh i use it one of my
favorite things uh about using them is
that they
trace
uh where the nutrients are coming from
and one of the things i keep reading all
the time is you never know where this
stuff is coming from everything from
seafood to vitamins so
uh you'll know where they come from
rituals one of a kind visible supply
chain uh now available for men women
teens ritual multivitamins are
scientifically developed to help support
different life stages so you could
tailor it to yourself uh your
multivitamins are delivered right to
your door every month with free shipping
always and you can start snooze or
cancel your subscription at any time a
lot of places don't do that look you
don't want it this month you hit one
button you don't want it anymore you hit
one button it's really tailored to you
if you don't love ritual within your
first month they'll refund your order so
what else you gonna try i mean you go to
the store every month if you're a
vitamin taker try something new and if
you don't why not start trying now get
key nutrients without all the bs rituals
offering our listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
hey babe to start your ritual today
speaking of hotels speaking hotels this
this episode's coming out um well it's
thursday already but this episode is
going to be coming out next week
speaking of hotels no no we might have
some huge news for me and sally babes oh
yeah i'm speaking on myself if i just
know if you live in the continental
united states don't book anything from
december 27th to december 31st don't
book anything the 20th could become
maybe maybe even the 26th to the 31st
if i were you i'd stop your plans from
the 26th to the 31st and just don't
eff and move yeah because we might be
coming to you especially if you live
around
if you're in the texas
missouri ohio area
i would say
leave the holidays open for the baby's
open if you're in the texas ohio
missouri
area tri-state area this is the official
tease the official tease we got some
things cooking cincinnati
[Laughter]
excessive farting and burping could be a
sign of depression study says well i got
the disgusting reason you should never
pass on passing gas yeah of course you
should never hold in your farts and
burps kids here's the thing growing up
is you really need to release bodily
fluids so burping flooding
gas masturbating all healthy habits that
have negative connotations right really
there should be it really if we want to
be a health if we're committed to being
a healthy society as we say we are yeah
then we should have a a burp
fart and masturbation room sure for the
kids right right right
i'd love for you to lead this cause
i mean what do you guys think don't you
think because it's the stigmas that we
have it's killing people yeah you want
me to hold in a fart and say and call me
a rude pig it's like i don't want to get
colon cancer yeah but you then think
though that everyone should just release
whatever they got wherever they are no
matter what i do well listen men women
children alike public street supermarket
whatever yeah because who just let it go
because when did the fart start and the
verb start getting negative connotations
like who put that into effect like why
is that you know like why is that a
problem is it really like why is the the
burp considered less offensive as well
than the fart yeah yeah what's the big
deal about coming from your butt or your
or the burp i get it
but
the burp the smell of but here's the
thing with a a fart here's the thing
with the fart please
please yeah yeah here's the thing with
the fart is the fart really doesn't
smell like any other type of appetizing
food maybe you could say the fart smells
like broccoli but the burp smells 100
like a hot dog yeah so the the burp at
times turns me off from a hot dog the
burp will turn me off from a food group
that i like more than the fart could
what i'm saying right and masturbation
smells like chlorine and i love pools
so every time i jump in a pool i'm like
oh somebody was horny
before we go i just want to get you your
thoughts on this article
megan trainer aka chrissy d
husband daryl sabara no relation to
sabaro's pizza have toilets next to each
other what do you think of that speaking
of burping and falling that is
yes
what yes
why who when this is a new thing the
celebrities are going nuts they're not
bathing or and they're [ __ ] next to each
other yeah what is that about you ever
see that snl sketch about the couple's
toilet no
they they're connected but they face
opposite ways so you sit right next to
each other and look at each other but it
was it's an snl sketch yes
like what are we talking about here
shout out snl new one of the new cast
members aristotle i worked with him uh
and doing a comedy central show he's a
great guy so it's nice to see like i
don't know the other two but it's nice
to see you know a really funny funny guy
get it right on do you think the
strength strengthens a relationship
is there any deets on this
she had a custom house built and they
built two toilets next to each other but
for what reason so they could literally
go to the bathroom next to each other
yeah like what's the point of this
nice house by the way
there we got two toilets sitting next to
each other and we've only pooped
together twice we pee at the scene at
the same time
sitting down is my question
yeah that's weird because then she's
sitting and he's standing i could easily
i could accidentally pee i missed the
seat constantly yeah
yeah as a matter of fact you're ready
for this today i was holding the baby
and i peed and it was one of those spray
pieces yeah you ever get a spray paint
before so i sprayed and i peed all over
the seat and the
and the um but i was holding the baby
and i just i was having a little back
issues because i fell yesterday you can
see it on my instagram i fell on my
camera so my back hurts and so i spray
pee all over the toilet and then the
um there's a guy doing construction in
my house like an overall handyman he's
like breaking up a bar a barn that we
have in the back so he um said you hired
one of those overall handy overall handy
guy so he i you know went away 15
minutes didn't clean up the pee i come
back he's cutting open the ceiling
because he thought in the bathroom he
thought there was a leak from the top
bathroom so now there's a huge hole in
my sink because he's looking for the
leak but it's really my piss on the seat
it was a yellow leak he well i guess
because i don't know maybe you know he's
colorblind
but there's an open hole in my ceiling
you got a leak he's like you got a leak
i came in to wash my hands i saw there
was pee all over i saw there was water
all over the toilet seat and on the
floor he goes so it must have because
she's taking a shower i said it's got to
be
and then thinking he's not you know his
butt so now but maybe there is a leak
yeah but i did pee on the toilet seat
and uh it's just one of those things
yeah man like i said i'm very tired yeah
but you didn't set the uh the baby down
and then clean it you forgot i no i
could no no i didn't forget i just my
back hurt i i was like it's too much
yeah because there have been times it is
funny being a dad
have you ever [ __ ] holding the baby oh
yeah sometimes you have to i guess that
thought has never crossed my mind but i
guess it's a necessity i [ __ ] the whole
time i put the baby down you got to do
your business you guys do what you got
to do well probably parents do it all
the time but you and i have never
crossed on my mind i don't think that
was allowed
i'll tell you exactly what i do what
i've done is i've there's been a couple
times that she's just crying crying
crying so you have to hold her she just
wants to be held i know it's spoiling
but she's my baby i'll do whatever if i
want so so so i i've held her before
when nobody's home held her while i need
to take a poop and then when i need to
wipe i put her in the sink like i just
let her sit in this because you can't
later i put her in the sink it's a
naturally ergonomic receptacle right
there she loves it yeah and then and
then i
flush you know wipe my butt flush the
toilet and then pick her up and wash my
hands and then i peel around when i get
outside wow that's what i do just right
in the sink have you been purelling
more than washing your hands like have
you been using purell
like like for example will you use the
bathroom and instead of washing your
hands just purell no you won't do that
no at home i don't use purell
but anywhere else i use it i have purell
hand sanitizers all over my house i
prefer it over washing my hands with
soap and water
uh but i know that it's not like let's
say you're both in the green room and he
went to bathroom and came out and did
purell and didn't wash his hands would
you judge that hmm i would i would have
to say that i think you're fine you're
using a an agent that's going to kill
ninety-nine would you be like his hands
might be gross
um
yeah because all you're doing is really
if you had any urine on your hand you're
just mixing the urine with the alcohol
and you're just cajoling it about
but when you put your hands under
running under running water the urine on
your hands is gonna go in down the drain
it's gonna be washed off right so you
might be killing the germs but you're
not really washing off the urine because
with purell your hands dry with it on it
right so it's better than nothing and i
probably would be oh
i don't know i mean if you came out and
said i had urine on my hand
and i just put purell on it i'm fine i'd
be like hey i'll take a pass on the
touching of it right but with the soap
and the water you're getting it off
because you're not uh listen cause
you're trying to have fun
you know how crazy i am you're gonna
think this is crazy because it's double
this is let me you want to peek into my
mind yes this is not the excellent well
not this is not excel this is how crazy
i am yeah i hate germs i am like a
little bit of a germ guy you know i i
have a low immune system so i don't like
to get sick i don't like sneezes i don't
like public restrooms i don't like to go
in them uh if i do go in them
i will look at every single urinal and
every single stall to see which one has
the least pooling of water below it and
then i will also stand back
even at the fear of exposing myself to
everyone i will stand back because i'm
not gonna put my soles of my shoes into
a puddle of urine underneath a urinal
right so i don't even go in but if i do
i roll up my pants
even like unless i'm wearing something
that's tapered if i have on like a
regular pant i roll them up i don't care
what i look like i rolled them up like
half half of my whatever but here's
something else i do when i'm taking a
public
urination in a stall
this is wild
if by chance i get in the urine on the
bowl i feel very i don't want to do that
i don't i feel guilty when i walk in and
see like that i'm disgusted i'll never
use it and i don't want to walk out and
some guy walks in there's nothing that
happens up when it happens i will take
like a hulk fist size
paper
like i will take like so much paper and
i will clean the public bowl around the
bowl myself
and throw it in so that i walk out and i
don't leave any urine on there but
that goes against everything i feel
because i don't want to go anywhere near
that bowl you understand so for me i
recoil at the fact of even going near
any germs in the bowl but in the same
exact breath i don't want to leave it
like that so i take a massive amount of
paper and i do maintenance on the public
bowl before i walk out can you believe
that now i walk right out and i and
believe me the the the depth of the
tissue is so much that i'm not touching
anything
but sometimes this other person like i i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm touching
but then i go right and i then i wash my
hands immediately but
that's that's messed up right i
shouldn't do that right i should just
let it be
this has been hey
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey we
gotta tell them about durham october
29th
durham performing arts center dorm is in
north carolina north carolina is in the
united states yes we will be there
co-headlining just like we did in
baltimore ask the people at the lyric
theater how much they love that show we
co-headline we do some stand-up and then
we come in at the end we take some
questions from the crowd you gotta be
there during performing arts center
october 29th